a year ago we held this debate in
exceptional circumstances we set
ourselves important challenges to curb the
spread of the pandemic guarantee
vaccination in europe
historic investments to mitigate the
economic effects of the crisis accompanied by
social measures that will leave no one
behind we have approved the next  generation
you and the money is beginning to
reach people, families and
companies from the
social democratic family we have not stopped
insisting that these investments must
be made with the future in mind, it must be
the beginning of a transition towards an
economic and social model  more sustainable
a true pact for sustainability
we have done a lot, yes, but we are only
halfway there, what worries me most is
that there will be an imbalance between
the three pillars of this new
economic and social model that we want to
build a resilient model that
guarantees well-being  of people
to avoid a fracture
as we advance in environmental policies
and strengthen the social climate fund, and
when I say strengthen the social climate fund
, I mean provide it with more
economic means and clear criteria in
its distribution from the ultimate objective
of any policy than any
strategy, the well-being of
that is what we should dedicate
our time to in our efforts and
I believe that we have not yet done
enough because the pandemic has
closed the difficulties and
inequalities of an unfair economic model
the most vulnerable groups are the ones
who have suffered the most  the
porto summit was a first step but we
need clear objectives to
continue its implementation
i also reiterate a fundamental issue
the gender dimension let me tell you
that for my group the announcement of the
commitment of the commission to present
a law against gender violence  in
europe it is without a doubt great
excellent news we carry  We have been
asking for years for this European law to fight
against the greatest scourge that exists at
the moment because in the world
there are women who lose their lives who are
murdered for the mere fact of being
women and we cannot remain
impassive in the face of this reality by talking about
moral duties  migration
and asylum policy because it is fundamental because
we are seeing what is happening in
afghanistan and also the need for
europe to speak with one voice on
foreign policy let's be brave it is
time to overcome unanimity to
decide on foreign policy and the
rule of law  fundamental the
european union are values ​​is defense of the
rule of law and we have to be firm
the commission has taken steps but it has to
be even more courageous and the group of
socialists and democrats is going to be in
it for today's europe and for
generations  future thank you very much
[Applause]